you didn't know what you were getting
into when you signed up for sores but
you guys did you knew that this was a
big deal so Daisy Ridley where were you
what were you doing when when you were
told you're going to be a big part of
this Star Wars world I was at the
theater at the Tristan Bates theater and
I was with my friend and I'd been at an
audition earlier on in the day and I got
an email for it lit she makes my heart
pound think about I got an email from JJ
and I thought like what saying hey can I
call you and I was like oh and I had to
ask for a charger then I had to do the
audition for this other thing and then I
went to the theater and then I had and
then I was taking my phone think he
hasn't called yet and I checked my
voicemail and there was a voice mails
like Oh God okay and then I could didn't
know how to call America because I had
never called America 3 they like bad
robot what's going on here and I thought
I basically had to convince him over the
phone that I was so mad I haven't
thought about this in ages I know it
makes your heart pump in it to make my
heart pump as mad and I thought I had to
convince him and he was going you know
this is gonna be this I was like I'm
ready I'm ready I can do it I can do it
any goes yeah yeah you're gonna be
installs and I was like oh and I was
outside the theater and the play had
started and it was a [__] long play
you can't celebrate no I literally went
in sat down next to my friend and was I
you